a mí el miedo de que el partido
comunista chino pueda tener acceso a los
datos de los usuarios en Estados Unidos
es la causa principal de esta
prohibición podría esta medida ser un
tema netamente político
lo es creo yo y en realidad es la
sospecha de que esto pueda llegar a
pasar durante años hemos visto un
tratamiento muy similar hacia compañía
compañías
como Huawei que de una u otra manera han
caído bajo esta misma lupa pero en la
cual el gobierno norteamericano nunca ha
podido probar en el caso de tiktok nunca
ha podido probar que efectivamente el
partido comunista tiene acceso a la
información Es más hace ya tres años
bajo el mandato del presidente Donald
Trump lo que se hizo fue garantizar que
la información de los norteamericanos no
saliera de servidores en suelo
norteamericano y aún a pesar de ello
estamos viendo digamos estas jugadas que
son jugadas netamente políticas ahora si
este es el miedo hay alguna otra forma
de solucionar la situación en lugar de
prohibir esta aplicación en su totalidad
Sí yo creo que eventualmente cuando
cuando lo vimos hace unos tres años la
solución era Oiga cómo hacemos para que
la información no tenga que salir y te
haga un paralelo rápido la Unión Europea
acaba de imponerle a meta una multa de
uno punto tres billones de dólares
precisamente por ese mismo tratamiento
sacar la información de los ciudadanos
europeos del territorio europeo y
llevárselo a servidores en Estados
Unidos Aquí podría pasar exactamente
cómo hacemos para garantizar que la
información de los norteamericanos no
sale es más esos servidores en los que
hoy corren la información de los
norteamericanos que utilizan tiktok que
es casi la mitad de la población
norteamericana están controlados por una
de las compañías más grandes
norteamericanas que como lo es Oracle
ahora Montana es el primer estado en
prohibirla pero la aplicación ya se
había restringido por ejemplo en varias
universidades del país y en teléfonos
celulares de empleados públicos sienta
esto un precedente para que otros
estados también la meten y posiblemente
también todo Estados Unidos
Sí y hoy hay discusiones serias digamos
que Creo yo que más a nivel Estatal Hoy
hay discusiones serias a nivel Federal
de si se pudiese llegar a hacer esto
claramente aquí hay todo un complejo
sistema alrededor de lo que para los
norteamericanos es súper importante como
lo es la libertad de expresión y es
precisamente la razón por la cual tanto
la compañía Como algunos de los usuarios
de tiktok en Montana han demandado
a la al al Estado precisamente diciendo
de gasto está infringiendo mi libertad
de expresión y vamos a ver si se
sostiene en las Cortes algo que yo creo
que puede llegar a ser complejo otra
cosa sería que a nivel Federal se tomara
la decisión pero de nuevo digamos que
tocan unos temas digamos de ética de
privacidad de libertad de expresión que
pueden complicar las cosas y llevar lo
que estás en una decisión que tome
bastantes años en lograr digamos un
acuerdo y finalmente se sabe que esta es
la fuente de ingreso de creadores de
contenido y también de personas que
tienen allí sus empresas además de
afectar Este modelo de negocio que otros
efectos negativos puede acarrear una
decisión como estas
yo creo que lo principal es cómo hacemos
el enforcement de una norma como esta Sí
una de las de los argumentos que tiene
la compañía Oiga hay una ley de comercio
en Estados Unidos que dice que los
estados no pueden interferir con lo que
tenga que ver con comercio transnacional
eso es digamos de responsabilidad
federal y no de los estados y aquí eso
es lo que pasa Hoy vemos creadores de
contenido que ganan plata digamos
compañías que utilizan la red para
vender sus productos para comercializar
sus productos para publicitar sus
servicios y el hecho de que en un estado
se diga que no se puede utilizar Pero
además no haya multas para quienes lo
usan sino solo digamos para el dueño
puede generar algunos problemas en Cómo
se va a hacer el informe y cómo hacemos
que esto sea realidad y ahí es donde yo
creo que esto es más pantomima que
cualquier otra cosa en medio de la de
una época electoral en donde los
republicanos necesitan de nuevo
conseguir un enemigo común que en este
caso va a ser el gobierno o el partido
comunista chino a propósito de esto que
usted menciona cree que de pronto este
tema va a marcar de Cara a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024
en China siempre es un elemento
fundamental en las discusiones digamos
gubernamentales y de una u otra manera
lo republicanos lo ven como un como una
herramienta que les puede servir Porque
de todas maneras
le estamos juntando dos cosas uno el
tema de China pero dos el tema los
jóvenes la mayor cantidad de usuarios de
tiktok en Estados Unidos son usuarios
jóvenes que tienden a ser más demócratas
que republicanos y Por ende digamos
también hay un juego político de cómo
hago para afectar esa ese movimiento
digamos de jóvenes que están en contra
de algunas políticas un poco más
ortodoxas un poco más republicanas
entonces aquí Viene un tema interesante
de ver cómo se va a mover un presidente
que o incluso utilizó a la red social
hace poco para empezar a llevar sus
mensajes relacionados con la reelección